scientists used to think that nuclear
war would get us mainly via explosions
radioactive fallout and electromagnetic
pulse
but a nuclear winter could kill much
more people it the US and Russia go at
it black smoke could smother Earth for
years and ruin farming so that most
humans would starve to death
so what makes so much smoke why does it
spread around the globe how can it stay
up for years
and how does it impact food production
I'm Max tegmark in MIT physics Professor
who is very curious about these
questions so let's explore them together
some of the world's leading nuclear
winter researchers kindly gave me
gigabytes of their state-of-the-art
simulation data so that I could make
these visualizations of what happens
here's the nuclear war between India and
Pakistan producing 47 megatons of black
carbon smoke
it's made by the nuclear explosions
themselves but by firestorms in large
cities that have been ignited by nuclear
Air Bursts like a campfire on steroids a
firestorm makes hot air and Smoke Rise
up while sucking in cooler air from the
sides this creates storm level winds
Fanning the Flames igniting anything
that can burn melting glass and some
metals and turning asphalt into a
flammable hot liquid
the Hiroshima bomb caused such a
firestorm and a large city like New
Delhi with over a hundred times greater
population can create much more smoke in
a firestorm sending plumes up into the
stratosphere far above any rain clouds
that would otherwise wash out the smoke
these simulations have also shown that
the Black Smoke Gets heated by sunlight
lofting it like a hot air balloon for up
to a decade
in the meantime Earth gets freezing cold
even during the summer with Farmland
from Kansas to the Ukraine cooling by
about 40 degrees Fahrenheit or 20
degrees centigrade and other regions
cooling almost twice as much
a new science paper estimates that a U.S
Russia War
star of over 5 billion people to death
including around 99 of those in the U.S
Russia Europe and China
let's see what such a U.S Russia war
with 150 megatons of black carbon smoke
would look like from space from the
direction of the Sun
we see that the high latitude jet
streams are so fast that it takes only a
few days for the smoke to spread across
much of the northern hemisphere
before you get too excited about moving
to Australia the spoiler alert is that
the smoke will eventually get there too
we obviously don't know how many people
will survive a nuclear war but I'm
confident that if it's even remotely as
bad as many scientists think then many
survivors will view it not as a failure
of individual politicians or countries
but of humanity itself
letting our children down like never
before
your friends about this video I made it
because the more people know about
nuclear winter
the less likely it is they will create
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]